ich hatte Bock auf ein neues Abenteuer
und diesmal nicht mit dem Zug Auto oder
Flugzeug sondern mit dem Fahrrad also
habe ich mich dazu entschieden 660 km
alleine mit dem E-Bike von meinem
Heimatort bis nach Paris zu fahren ich
habe mir als Ziel gesetzt die Strecke in
drei Tagen zu bewältigen meine Eltern
und Freunde meinen ich brauche safe 5 da
mein E-Bike nur maximal 25 km/h fährt
aber seht selbst und damit guten Morgen
Leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es
gut ihr seht schon ich sehe ein bisschen
anders aus als sonst und zwar habe ich
Sport sondern zumindest oben rum wie
sollte es anders sein die nächsten Tage
werden wieder extrem heiß ich glaube
über 30 Grad jeden Tag kurze
Vorgeschichte ich bin jetzt so oft
irgendwo mit dem Flugzeug hingeflogen
oder mit dem Auto irgendwo hingefahren
oder mit dem Zug aber noch nie und
wirklich auch noch nie in meinem Leben
irgendwie eine weite Strecke mit dem
Fahrrad gefahren ich bin mal 50 oder 60
km gefahren aber noch nie so mehrere
hundert und ich hatte da einfach mal
Bock drauf und dachte mir hey du fährst
mit dem Fahrrad nach Frankreich nach
Paris kein Plan ich würde es halt so
schnell schaffen wie möglich ich habe
mir drei Tage als Ziel gesetzt also
jeden Tag etwas mehr als 200 km ich weiß
dass es sehr sehr sportlich ich befinde
mich jetzt gerade hier noch bei meinen
Eltern das ist mein Fahrrad das habe ich
zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen dafür so
sieht das auf jeden Fall aus ich stelle
es euch später noch mal ein bisschen
genauer vor ich habe das letzte Woche
ausgepackt wir switchen noch mal kurz
hin schaut mal was gerade angekommen ist
mein neues E-Werk Digger geil
und so sieht das jetzt präpariert aus
ich habe mir einen Helm gekauft wir
haben schon im Wasser ich habe mir auch
noch eine Tasche besorgt mein Rucksack
kommt hier drauf Leute ich glaube es
wird wirklich ein geiles Abenteuer ich
habe richtig Bock einfach alleine
Fahrrad fahren ich bin echt gespannt was
passiert und so wir haben jetzt schon
10:30 Uhr und ich muss los das Fahrrad
zeige ich euch später noch mal ein
bisschen genauer ja ist ein E-Bike also
es kann auch ne unterstützen fahren okay
Leute los geht's Alter ich weiß auch
nicht was ich mir da vorgenommen habe
wirklich so sich übrigens mit Helm was
ich glaube ich hatte noch nie in einem
Youtube Video ein Mann ich bin unterwegs
noch für die Fahrt die habe ich gerade
noch in der Tasche ich weiß noch nicht
wo ich die anbringen soll alles ein
bisschen hektisch mal gucken was
passiert die nächsten Tage ich bin echt
gespannt irgendwie machen sich auch alle
Sorgen um mich dass ich da nicht heile
ankomme aber was ich nicht alles schon
gemacht
also Abfahrt
okay Leute erste zwei Kilometer
geschafft ey direkt neben meinem Wohnort
gibt es einfach Alpakas ich habe das
noch nie wahrgenommen aber sind noch
welche oder guck mal der da hinten
hey wie geil
so Pause Leute ich musste schon wieder
anhalten keine Sorge das passiert ist
nicht so oft ich bin jetzt ungefähr 10
km von zu Hause weg noch gar nicht so
weit aber ich war hier schon so lange
nicht mehr und das ist echt krass ich
war hier früher immer mit meinem Opa
also ein Stromberg und genau auf dieser
Straße da vorne kommt gleich zum
Bauernhof das ist einfach jetzt schon 18
19 20 Jahre her ist so krass aber ich
kann mich noch daran erinnern obwohl ich
immer von so einem Hund gejagt und habe
geschrieben ich hatte auch richtig Panik
von diesem Ding und ich weiß noch mein
Opa hat es gar nicht gejuckt der hat
immer dann mit so einem Typen da
gequatscht und ich hatte da die meine
Todesangst ja da kommen gerade
Erinnerungen hoch und ich war schon so
lange nicht mehr obwohl es so 10
Kilometer weit weg ist von meinem von
meinem Heimatdorf Heimatstadt weiter
geht's okay die ersten 45 km sind
geschafft ich bin jetzt gerade in Hamm
hier siehst du auch wirklich schön aus
obwohl eigentlich haben nicht schön ist
zumindest der Bahnhof wobei ich habe
erst 44,4 Kilometer gut eineinhalb
Stunden unterwegs und habe jetzt auch
hier die GoPro angebracht an meinen Helm
weiter geht's Leute wir müssen noch
einiges reißen das Ziel für heute wird
übrigens mindestens Köln sein aber ich
denke ich habe es auch noch ein bisschen
weiter es ist 12:30 Uhr weiter geht's so
Leute GoPro ist installiert ich wäre
gerne weiter geradeaus gefahren wir
müssen jetzt hier hoch und dann oben
über die Brücke let's go
das Fahrrad ist ja auch so ein
tracking-bike ich hoffe
ihr könnt mich heute hier schon noch
sehen wo geil ein Fluss und hier geht's
jetzt rechts runter
[Musik]
so jetzt geht's drei Kilometer weiter
geradeaus und dann erstmal gleich
irgendwas Essen ich bin auf jeden Fall
jetzt gut im Flow die Beine sind warm
ja übrigens an alle Leute die rum
meckern dass ich ja nicht mit normalen
Fahrrad fahre ihr könnt es ja erstmal
selber nachmachen mit dem E-Bike ich bin
richtig am schwitzen schon also es geht
auch gut in die Oberschenkel der
unterstützt ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit
nur wenn es bergauf geht jetzt gerade so
ein bisschen hier geht's hoch aber
Attacke auf Null bei Friseurteam gemacht
haben Alter das war auch anders geplant
Augen zu und schnell durch ne
so endlich wieder normale Strecke oder
halten schöner Weg da oben verlaufen
Bahnschienen könnte mich natürlich auch
Entzug setzen und nach Paris fahren aber
nein heute mit Fahrrad was macht mir
auch deutlich mehr Spaß als in dem Zug
zu sitzen irgendwie geht zwar nicht so
schnell aber egal und das meine ich hier
mit dem Fahrrad also es fährt wirklich
brutal auch hier wenn es uneben ist
extrem geil so Leute ich bin
mittlerweile in Unna ist in NRW keine
Ahnung ob ihr das kennen ich brauche
jetzt erstmal was zu essen wow
egal
70 km geknackt was besseres als im
käseding hier habe ich gefunden dann
geht's weiter Richtung Dortmund bin ich
aber gleich schon da also Dortmund habe
ich gleich Leute
Rucksack ich habe übrigens jetzt zur
Stelle Brille auf ganzer Rucksack auf
die Straße geflogen irgendwie sind die
Bänder hier abgegangen das habe ich hier
noch ein bisschen fester gemacht ich bin
übrigens gerade irgendwo hinter Solingen
ich mache gleich noch eine Pause dann
erkläre ich euch wie es weitergeht wir
haben jetzt 16:40 Uhr es gibt auf jeden
Fall mit diesen Dingen nichts nervigeres
als am Abend ehrlich ich stehe die ganze
Zeit nur am Ampeln hier okay
genau das Ruhrgebiet habe ich so
größtenteils hinter mir jetzt sind die
Straßen wieder so aus ich habe die GoPro
wieder auf dem Kopf also ich habe heute
schon so viel verschiedene Landschaften
gesehen hier ist jetzt wieder die Ruhe
weg und eben war es einfach nur stressig
jetzt gleich hier wird es wieder schön
grün oh geil ey wirklich nach 80 km
wieder ein Fahrradweg glaube ich ah und
das ist ein bisschen frischer ich habe
so geswettet eben und rein in den ortweg
zu welchem Ort der mich wohl führt oh
super Fahrradstraße KFZ frei ehrlich das
erste Mal dass ich mich über sowas freue
in meinem Leben und jetzt noch mal
Endspurt ich habe noch 32 km vor mir bis
zu meinem ersten nächtigungsstopp
mit der Brille sehe ich eher so aus als
wäre ich in Düsseldorf losgefahren oder
Fahren
richtig Spaß ne trotzdem weiß ich dass
ich morgen komplett Muskelkater habe
weiß ich nicht gewöhnen können zumindest
nicht dieses Fahrrad fahren oder ist der
Rhein
wow
boah okay das müssen wir kurz da müssen
wir ein Foto machen also ich bin jetzt
irgendwo glaube ich zwischen Düsseldorf
und Köln muss ich sagen
kalt
[Musik]
und an dieser Stelle auch schaut zu
miniway Bikes die haben mir nämlich
diese schöne fahrradstiefel gestellt und
ich muss sagen es macht so unfassbar
Spaß ich glaube ihr habt schon gesehen
ich hatte auf meiner Reise übrigens auch
drei Akkus für mein E-Bike dabei damit
ich halt wirklich möglichst weit komme
und wenn man etwas sparsam fährt hält
ein Akku sogar bis zu 128 km bei mir
waren es immer so 80 bis 100 und ja ich
zeig's euch hier noch mal auch ein paar
Detailaufnahmen aber man kann sehen es
ist wirklich geil bis jetzt bin ich voll
zufrieden auch mit den Reifen und so
dass sie nicht kaputt gehen können hier
macht man es an dann kann man sich auch
verschiedene Informationen geben lassen
hier habe ich jetzt ein Handyhalterung
angebracht und hier haben wir die
Schaltung Klingel UPS oh hier muss ich
aufpassen das ist übrigens das Zebra
oder in Deutschland Zebra Modell so
wirklich schön für Cross
Landschaften geeignet und ja ich freue
mich auf jeden Fall richtig auf die
nächsten Tage die ich mit dem Ding noch
richtig durchziehen kann ich muss jetzt
gleich auf einmal schon meinen Akku
wechseln weil der ist leer ganz cool ist
noch wenn jetzt das Video schaut euch am
Ende denkt so ein Fahrrad will ich auch
haben ich habe einen Code für euch da
gibt's aber auch nicht Rabatt und
einfach Alex eingeben wenn ihr euch dann
dort ein Sachen bestellt jetzt wünsche
ich euch aber viel Spaß mit dem Video
wir fahren weiter und erstmal werde ich
jetzt heute Nacht bei den Eltern von
meiner Freundin übernachten die wohnen
nämlich ich sag mal in der Mitte von
Köln und der holländischen Grenze und
das sieht gut auf dem Weg und dann muss
ich mir halt kein Hotel buchen oder
irgendwo Zeiten also labern war nicht
lange und fahren direkt mal weiter mein
Arsch brennt zwar wie Sau aber das habe
ich jetzt einfach schon gelernt zu
ignorieren irgendwann ist ja Schmerzen
[Musik]
Satteltaschen
Digger ich wusste gar nicht dass es hier
sowas gibt ne okay Leute ich bin
mittlerweile auf der anderen Seite ich
hatte keinen Bargeld dabei ne weil ich
habe jetzt heute noch nicht damit
gerechnet dass ich Fähre fahre klar ist
es immer gut Bargeld in der Tasche zu
haben das weiß ich auch von meinen
Reisen aber ich hatte halt gerade keins
da fahre ich den Typ so kann ich auch
mit Karte bezahlen das war so ein rein
in der Sache mit Karte natürlich
bezahlen und dann hat er mir aber eine
netter andere Passagier hat mich damit
genommen weil er hatte irgendwie so eine
Doppelkarte und dieser Boots Kapitän so
zu den anderen mein Gott da will der
junge her damit Karte bezahlen das ist
so ein Ding in eurer Generation das sind
die Bargeld dabei ja und erzählt er eben
dass ich mit Karte zahlen wollte dann
hat er nur noch dass er sein Lolli
Mitbewohner nimmt also so langsam ist
aber lustig was auch wirklich immer
super ist Fahrradweg einfach plötzlich
vorbei aber jetzt schon öfter jetzt muss
ich anscheinend hier ja also
ungefährlich ist es nicht aber was
willst du machen doch 18 km dann habe
ich für heute geschafft
danke und der Radfahrern hilft man sich
halt einfach nur ist ganz normal macht
das schon ewig Leute kurz vom Ziel gebt
euch mal dieses riesige
braunkohleberg oder ich glaube es
Braunkohle ich wusste gar nicht dass das
so fett ist boah so Leute nicht am
Morgen ich habe jetzt hier eine schlafen
hallo hallo die nächste tappe steht an
ich habe gestern nicht mehr gefilmt ich
war richtig k.o ich habe ein bisschen
Probleme mein Arm tut ziemlich weh sonst
geht aber alles ich habe jetzt auch so
eine Radlerhose dabei und mache mich
jetzt auf die nächste tappe gestern habe
ich etwas mehr als 180 oder sogar eine
100 Kampf 190 km gefahren war schon hart
aber es war auf jeden Fall noch Luft
nach oben und heute habe ich eigentlich
die längste tappe vor mir ich versuche
tatsächlich bis nach Rheins oder Rems
ich weiß nicht genau wie man es
ausspricht zu kommen das sind ja knapp
300 km oder ich glaube sogar bisschen
mehr als 200 km ziemlich unrealistisch
aber immer hohe Ziele setzen und
vielleicht habe ich ja los geht's ich
habe den ganzen Tag Zeit und wenn ich
das heute schaffe dann komme ich morgen
auf jeden Fall safe bis nach Paris auch
schon relativ früh
aus wie ein Radprofi oder von der Tour
de France auf
ich habe so semi Bock aber es wird schon
also gestern war nur die letzten 20 km
hart auf geht's okay ich bin wieder
unterwegs heute im Tanktop die ersten 30
oder 35 km habe ich jetzt schon hinter
mir ich habe mir hier auch eine neue App
gekauft und zwar komoot 20 € hat das
gekostet aber da soll es wohl bessere
Fahrradwege geben und man fährt nicht
die ganze Zeit an irgendwelchen Straße
lang und dann navigiert mich jetzt lang
aber bis jetzt ist eigentlich ganz nice
mein erstes Ziel heute zum Mittag wird
sein die belgische Stadt Lüttich bzw ich
und dann geht's aber auch zeitnah weiter
weil ich hoffe ich komme morgen in Paris
an es wird auf jeden Fall ein harter
Kampf jetzt gestern war glaube ich ein
Witz im Vergleich zu dem was ich mir
heute vorgenommen habe nicht meckern
einfach machen aber Vorsicht Kinder
voraus danke wenn ich freiwillig fahre
und hier die Wasserflasche drauf habe
wackelt immer leicht aber ich bin noch
nicht hingefallen und das soll auch so
bleiben
das einzige Problem was ich wirklich
habe ich gehe aktiv jetzt ins
Fitnessstudio Seiten halben Jahr und ich
habe meinen Armen so ein bisschen über
strapaziert hä gestern zu Anfang hatte
ich auch hier halt schon Schmerzen wenn
man die ganze Zeit ja so sitzt und den
Abend so durchstrecken und auch belastet
irgendwann ging das aber weg also ich
habe so rausgefahren ich hoffe dass dir
gleich wieder weg weil heute ist der
Schmerz irgendwie noch ein bisschen
schlimmer als gestern naja
[Musik]
hallo naja das Schlimmste sind
eigentlich diese Wege wo es einfach nur
stumpf gerade ausgeht ich fahre jetzt
schon seit mindestens 10 km einfach
stumpf nämlich der Straße lang und das
ist nervig weil es einfach langweilig
ist auch Polizei
fahre ich dann auf der richtigen Seite
sonst gibt's Ärger vielleicht
kein Problem ich muss ja eh Links hier
mal wieder nicht aufs Navi geachtet oh
immer noch falsche Seite ja klasse der
kaufe ich mir extra 20 € und dann vor so
einem geschlossenen Fahrradweg zu stehen
ähm ich habe mich glaube ich Verfahren
nee ich muss Richtung Aachen ich muss
bisschen nach Paris sogar
ja danke
besser Richtung Altenburg oder ist das
einfach ja dann mache ich das so alles
klar ich danke Ihnen
dann noch einen schönen Tag ne dann
fahren wir jetzt mal Richtung Altenburg
und hoffen dann wer fährt denn so eine
Scheiße das ist doch geil aus der Weg
oder kurze Zwischenpause ich bin
mittlerweile einfach schon in Holland es
kam kein Schild auf dem Radweg ich habe
plötzlich eine Nachricht bekommen auf
mein Handy ja herzlich willkommen in den
Niederlanden ich verstehe zwar die
Sprache nicht aber ich glaube ich habe
schon ein paar Komplimente für meinen
Fahrrad bekommen die sind hier in
Holland total fahrradbegeistert man hat
auch überall richtig dicke Fahrradwege
es gibt teilweise Fahrradstraßen die
sind größer als die richtige Straße
daneben werdet ihr gleich noch sehen ich
setze die GoPro wieder auf und ja mega
schön hier und Bewohner gleich kommt
Maastricht und dann bin ich aus Holland
auch schon wieder raus also ich glaube
es sind so 40 Kilometer die ich durch
Holland gefahren bin dann okay bis jetzt
haben wir 59,5 km zurückgelegt 42 noch
bis nötig da wollte ich ja dann
Essenspause einlegen und ich habe zwei
Stunden 34 gebraucht ja so weiter geht's
ich habe auch noch eine Challenge die
auf mich zukommt und zwar habe ich
keinen Plan wie ich von Paris
nach Hause kommen soll weil diese
thaleszüge nach Deutschland fahren die
nehmen mein Fahrrad nicht mit also
zumindest müsste ich es auseinanderbauen
wieder und in eine Plastikfolie packen
und keine Ahnung das ist ein bisschen
kompliziert egal irgendwie wird das
schon das ist Holland Radweg einfach
breiter als die Straße und das ist jetzt
nicht nur eine Straße wo man in die
Richtung fahren darf als Auto du kannst
auch in die Richtung fahren auch nee
komm es geht mir so auf den Sack nicht
schon wieder warte mal ist das für
Fahrradfahrer
wir sind okay
weiter geht's heute geht mein Akku auch
ein bisschen schneller weg als gestern
so Leute ich hoffe ihr könnt es erkennen
genau neben mir also in diese Richtung
ist jetzt Maastricht ich würde sagen 2
km Luftlinie dann ja wäre das da und ich
bin jetzt in ungefähr 5 km an der
belgischen Grenze und dann sind wir in
Lesch oder halt Lüttich ja also noch
nicht direkt aber es sind noch 25 km ca
und dann machen wir erstmal ein bisschen
Pause so jetzt geht's erstmal wieder
runter 40 von 50 50 ja 50
ist die Grenze super Belgien okay
vielleicht doch nicht hä
nee ich bin noch nicht in Belgien ich
bin jetzt was ist denn das hier bin ich
blöd Limburg ja okay also müsste das ja
aber auch noch holländisch also die
sprechende holländisch wobei die hat
teilweise in Belgien auf Deutsch
sprechen dann wieder ach komm musst du
nicht durchblicken wir wollen ja auch
nach Paris da sprechen diese Welt ich
weiß Französisch ich zitiere aus
Wikipedia Limburg heißt die südlichste
der 12 Provinz in der Niederlande die
Grenzen im Osten Deutschland und im
Westen oder Südwesten alle eine
belgische Provinz die ebenfalls Limburg
heißt alles klar das war aber
tatsächlich schon das belgische Limburg
verstanden oder was ist das denn jetzt
hier oh geil
sieht doch schön aus
boah ich würde da übelst gerne jetzt
reinspringen ne
die Aussicht hier ist zwar herrlich
Problem ist mein erster Akku ist leer
und ich werde noch nicht tauschen jetzt
ich bin auch gleich in Lüttich nur es
ist wirklich hart vor allem hier in der
Sonne und so
naja noch ungefähr 5 km und dann sind
wir da ich habe hier meine Powerbank in
meiner Unterhose damit ich ein bisschen
laden kann also mit den dicken Reifen
komplett ohne Antrieb zu fahren ist
schon anstrengend so Leute ich habe es
geschafft das hier ist nötig wie auch
immer wahrscheinlich Aussprache wieder
komplett daneben aber jetzt habe ich
erstmal wo ich hier hin gehe und dann
muss ich aber auch zeitnah Weiterkommen
aber erstmal auf jeden Fall was essen ey
ich bin jetzt auf jeden Fall im Zentrum
von Lüttich ja
geile Brücke ne angekommen nötig hatte
ich nicht mal die Hälfte meines Trips
nach Paris rum über 350 km lagen noch
vor mir und wir hatten schon 15 Uhr
eigentlich wollte ich über die
französische stadtschale will mich jetzt
fahren ich habe meinen Weg allerdings
noch weiter nördlich durch weitere
belgische Städte angepasst weil ich
sowohl die besseren Fahrradstraßen
erwischt habe und das schlimmste ist
eigentlich wenn du irgendwo ankommst es
ist ja nicht okay du bist jetzt 200 km
Fahrrad gefahren und kannst Dich
ausruhen ich muss mir noch ein Hotel
suchen ich muss gucken was ich mit
meinen Sachen mache und so weiter das
ist eigentlich das Schlimmste ich bin
durch die nächste französische Stadt
gefahren ich musste meine Route ändern
oder ich habe meine Route ein bisschen
angepasst wir fahren jetzt ein bisschen
weiter ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich
euch gerade eigentlich sagen wollte die
Konzentration ist so Geistern am Arsch
das ist eigentlich mein größtes Problem
ich muss so aufpassen auf jeden Fall
habe ich die Route ein bisschen weiter
nördlich glaube ich angepasst weil dort
halt Fahrradwege sind die deutlich
besser sein soll oder überhaupt Fahrrad
will sind weil in Frankreich ist es wohl
nicht so fahrradfreundlich haben wir
sehr viele geschrieben und ich bin jetzt
gerade durch
Schule war oder so gefahren das Ding ist
der jetzt mittlerweile schon nach acht
gleich wird's dunkel ich habe noch 43 km
vor mir bis zum nächsten Hotel hat nicht
mehr allzu viel Akku das einzige boah
geil das einzige Gute ist
ich komme jetzt gleich über die Grenze
nach Frankreich also dann sind wir
endlich mal in Frankreich und ich habe
heute bis jetzt 190 km zurückgelegt aber
42 kommen noch und eigentlich müsste ich
noch mehr schaffen aber ich glaube das
wird heute eng wir werden sehen so ich
muss nur noch kurz was zu Trinken kaufen
aber irgendwie nur noch dass ich jetzt
hier beklaut werde hallo
okay
ich bin auf einer halben Autobahn
eigentlich oh mann ich will hier runter
das war echt dumm also eins könnt ihr
mir glauben ich wurde noch nie bei
irgendein Videos so gechallenge wie hier
das ist schon echt hart ich bin jetzt
seit 10 30 wenig losgefahren seit fast
zehn Stunden bin ich unterwegs und jetzt
sehen wir hier erstmal gleich die
Autobahn Abfahrt scheiße scheiße ich
muss da oben lang
richtig die dümmste Entscheidung
bis hier Achtung Fahrradfahrer auf der
Autobahn bei ausländischen Leute die
keinen Plan haben kann ich verstehen
dass das mal aus Versehen passiert wie
bei mir jetzt wegen meinem Navi aber
eigentlich huhu noch mal Glück gehabt
Burger King ich überlege ob ich meine
Batterie laden soll eigentlich nee komm
ich ziehe jetzt durch also fehlt nur
noch das hier mir jetzt vielleicht so
ein Clown vor die vor die Linse hüpft so
wie das hier aussieht noch ist es zum
Glück hell
Leute ich bin nicht am Ende es lief
eigentlich ganz gut ich habe mich jetzt
verfahren bin hier neben der Autobahn
hier geht's nicht weiter ich bin gerade
gefahren das ist einfach nur hart gleich
Akku leer scheiß Scheiße wirklich können
heulen Leute alles oder nichts wenn
dieser Weg jetzt hier mich ins ausbringt
dann
ist vorbei ihr müsst jetzt gleich einen
Weg kommen da hinten stimme ich dann
weiterfahren kann und ich hoffe dass das
auch so ist 300 Meter boah mein Gott ich
habe heute schon 20 fliegen gefressen
also ohne Scheiß immer weiter
200 m
aua
oh mein Gott
[Applaus]
noch schlimmer Leute
schaut mal gut dass ich da nicht drauf
gefallen bin
ich hatte mir gerade wirklich das
Schlüsselbein oder so brechen können ich
bin noch nie so über länger gefetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen Adrenalin-Kick
jetzt bin ich wieder wach hier war
gerade irgendwie einen Hund dachte ich
oder ein Reh oder ein Wolf na das wäre
es jetzt noch vorne ist der Weg 28 km
noch meine GoPro ist total schief ich
war zwar hier schon in Frankreich aber
in der angrenzenden Region in Belgien
namens Wallonien leben einige Wölfe und
ich bin mir sicher es war entweder ein
Hund oder tatsächlich einen Wolf der
dann vermutlich abgecheckt ist als sie
mich aufs Maul gelegt habe Leute ich
habe es geschafft und ich habe extra
noch angehalten um euch das zu zeigen
schaut mal es ist echt wie im Film ich
komme mir an nachts da oben leuchtet
sowas und das ist einfach mein Hotel
wenn es da ist noch was zu essen gibt
das wäre krass geschafft ich bin im
Hotel ich bin so fertig boah der Rest
weiß oder die letzten 20 km waren so
hart irgendwo gab es dieses Hotelzimmer
so sieht das hier aus und ich muss sagen
wenn man noch draußen guckt wirklich
sehr sehr schön bin zwar eigentlich
gefühlt fast der einzige hier ein
bisschen gruselig auch aber na ja das
Ding hat auch ganz gute Bewertungen und
ich möchte jetzt einfach nur pennen
Leute bis morgen
gut guten Morgen Leute
6:30 Uhr so sieht das jetzt hier aus ich
finde mich jetzt gleich sofort wieder
aufs Fahrrad weil ich habe mir
vorgenommen ich will halt unbedingt nach
Paris kommen
[Musik]
schon seit einiger Zeit hier an dem
Fluss lang wolltest mal kurz einmal
aufnehmen sehr sehr entspannt also wenn
die ganze Reise so aussehen würde würde
ich mich überhaupt nicht beschweren das
wäre ultra geil leider habe ich gestern
komplett das Gegenteil erlebt und
eigentlich fast den ganzen Tag aber hier
ist es wirklich sehr sehr schön
ich habe jetzt noch so
180 heute irgendwie packen gestern habe
ich auch gepackt von daher oh jetzt
wird's kritisch
bitte lass mich in Ruhe
[Musik]
bin auch von den beiden hier eigentlich
ziemlich fit also ich habe bisschen
Muskelkater aber es geht eigentlich also
jetzt let's go so Leute ersten 50 km
sind geschafft denke dass ich in acht
Stunden ca da sein werde
ich packe das heute
hoffe ich
esse noch 120 km bis Paris ich gehe
jetzt in dieser kleinen piss-stadt mir
noch Geld abheben wir haben jetzt 12:15
Uhr und ich denke ich werde so um 17 Uhr
18 Uhr in Paris sein wenn ich jetzt
durchziehe müssen gerade mal wieder eine
kleine Pause einlegen ich bin jetzt
schon in irgendeinem vor Ort von Paris
also sieht eigentlich ganz süß aus hier
und ich muss jetzt auch 34 km fahren
dann bin ich endlich am Eiffelturm also
ja Endspurt ich glaube ich habe in
diesem Video schon 20 mal endspur gesagt
bin jetzt ja 9 1/2 Stunden unterwegs ich
habe gar keinen Bock auf diesen Paris
Verkehr jetzt das ist glaube ich Horror
egal wir müssen durch ja Leute das sieht
doch geil aus das sieht nach Paris aus
ich bin jetzt gerade hier so wirklich
relativ Zentrum gekommen jetzt gehst du
noch zum Eiffelturm 6 km also jetzt muss
ich mich auf jeden Fall noch mal
konzentrieren sind zwar ziemlich am
Arsch aber hier will ich jetzt auch
nicht überfahren werden eigentlich
müsste ich auch einmal durch den
Triumph fahren da wo auch die Toilette
angeht hier gibt's sogar Verkehrszeichen
für die aber ich kann mal gekonnt
ignoriert hey leute es ist so bodenlos
was ich hier mache ist es einfach also
in Deutschland wäre ich wenn ich schon
fünf Anzeigen kassiert
also der Verkehr in Paris ist wirklich
eine Katastrophe
in katastrop Freunde sind hello I'm from
Germany
[Musik]
Video mit Gesicht mir egal übrigens ach
so ich habe gerade die Kamera gemacht um
zu sagen dass ich ein Eiffelturm gesehen
habe aber ihr habt noch nicht gesehen
weil ich glaube da waren dann schon
wieder Bäume also in Deutschland
Ärger geben weil ich auf der falschen
Seite fahre aber ich glaube okay
geil
ich war ja schon einmal im Eiffelturm
auch oben drauf aber jetzt sind wir nur
davor mit Fahrrad
let's go Endspurt oh mein Gott ich habe
es geschafft oh mein Gott
Digger ich hätte es echt
boah es ist so befriedigend dass ich
endlich da bin
Alter geilo
ah
so wer macht jetzt hier kurz ein Foto
von mir
hammermäßig so hier suche mir jetzt eben
ein Foto Spot ich muss das ja auch auf
Instagram festhalten Instagram folgen
so Leute ich habe es geschafft wir haben
jetzt 17:30 Uhr das heißt ich war
insgesamt knapp 56 Stunden unterwegs
Blende euch auch hier noch mal genau die
Route ein wie viel Kilometer ist jetzt
gesamt waren ich muss es mal zu Hause in
Ruhe tracken keine Ahnung wohnen jetzt
sehr gerne den Kanal checkt gern mieway
Bikes ab danke für das Fahrrad das habe
ich gut gebrauchen können falls noch
irgendwas passiert in Paris kommt
natürlich noch mit rein ich bin an dem
Tag logischerweise nicht mehr
zurückgefahren der atmen in Paris war
aber richtig nice ich habe noch drei
Freunde von mir getroffen wir waren im
Club wir waren cool Essen und Paris hat
mir richtig gut gefallen ich war auch
erst das zweite Mal da geiler Trip mit
einem richtig geilen Abschluss mir hat
Spaß gemacht und ich bin froh dass sie
es durchgezogen hat haut rein Leute ciao